ah c'était un empire en afrique on
attend bien sûr vos réactions sur le
hashtag docu débat judith rue f c'est
vous qui avez réalisé ce documentaire
merci d'être avec nous vos côtés yves le
bars bienvenus vous êtes président du
comité français pour la solidarité
internationale
en face de vous philippe hugon bienvenue
à vous vous êtes professeur émérite à
l'université paris ouest nanterre
directeur de recherche à l'iris
spécialiste de l'afrique et enfin jean
marie bockel bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur du haut-rhin ancien secrétaire
d'état à la coopération
coauteur du rapport d'information au
sénat intitulé l'afrique est notre
avenir bienvenue à tous alors judith
ruef votre documentaire traite d'un
problème bien particulier qui est ce
conflit entre nestlé et codilait comment
vous en avez eu connaissance de dossiers
alors j'ai remonté un pas en arrière en
fait dix ans plus tôt parce que je pense
est intéressant j'ai été correspondante
du journal libération en côte d'ivoire
et j'ai voulu faire un article sur magie
qu'on voit au début du film
voilà les petits cubes rouge et jaune
qui sont on peut pas se promener en côte
d'ivoire et partout en afrique de
l'ouest sont croisés magie dans les
marchés à la télé dans les bistrots
partout et j'avais envie de faire un
papier sur ce succès marketing en fait
et donc j'ai contacté la filiale de
nestlé à abidjan et la porte close on me
renvoie sur le siège donc à vevey
c'était un peu bizarre ce que je dis
correspondante en côte d'ivoire et ont
dû aller chercher des informations sur
l'afrique de l'ouest
et là pas de réponse enfin ont fait
traîner voilà donc je suis resté sur
ceux sur cet échec et c'est l'idée a
germé dans ma tête et lison je
laisser travailler sur dc en afrique et
en faisant des recherches en creusant
mais si je raconte ça c'est aussi parce
que je pense qu'une des questions qui
est posée dans le film et qui voit là
c'est qu'elle compte rendre ces
multinationales parce que répondre à des
journalistes
c'est aussi rendre des comptes aux
citoyens finalement et elles ont un
pouvoir énorme et politiques et
économiques bien sûr mais aussi
politique qu'on pense à la force du
lobby agro-industriel
à bruxelles voilà donc mais met tout de
suite j'ai trouvé une entreprise fermée
qui n'avaient pas tellement envie de
parler aux journalistes et on voit aussi
dans ce film est alors ce conflit que
vous illustrez elle montre bien une
différence très nette entre le discours
officiel des firmes et la réalité sur le
terrain fait c'est ça que vous vouliez
montrer oui notamment
oui parce que sur sur le papier c'est
formidable et je pense que c'est pas
uniquement
enfin il ya une part de vérité de bonne
volonté de ces groupes de dire on est
responsable on s'intéresse et à
l'environnement social et à
l'environnement tout court aux
conditions écologiques etc ont fait des
rapports sur ces questions là on
travaille avec des ong sur ces questions
là donc une bonne volonté beaucoup de
com aussi pour le dire des choses très
joli sur le papier quand même et puis
après il ya le terrain et vu le
gigantisme de ces sociétés
multinationales forcément sur le terrain
c'est tout autre chose qu on constate
alors vous parlez de nestlé du cameroun
mais vous auriez aussi pu choisir une
illustration avec une autre
multinationale et un autre pays du sud
absolument absolument 1 et ce l'est pour
moi était l'emblème et c'est d'ailleurs
le parce que c'est plus gros groupes
agroalimentaires du monde le numéro un
mondial loin devant notre champion à
nous français danone et donc en ce sens
là je me suis intéressé à 1 et cela en
tant que navire amiral est de
l'agroalimentaire alors vous parlez de
l'industrie agroalimentaire des effets
de la mondialisation sur l'afrique vous
mettez aussi en lumière le peu de
réglementation de ces pays qui font de
l'afrique nous trois
à par exemple des scandales sanitaires
comme dans les années 70 avec le lait en
poudre qui a provoqué la mort de
nombreux nourrisson est ce que des
scandales de ce type là sont encore
possibles en 2015
des scandales aussi important peut-être
pas parce que quand même ils ont ils ont
appris on va dire ils ont été très mais
ce scandale a été très médiatisée et
leur a fait du mal là où ça leur fait
mal c'est-à-dire à leur image donc on va
dire que ils font attention mais des
histoires assez récemment en chine enfin
ça reste quand même oui ça vous et vos
réactions à ce documentaire yves là bas
j'ai trouvé effectivement très
intéressant et qui fait écho un certain
nombre d' aventure dans lesquels dans ma
vie de responsables des ong
je me suis trouvée confrontée en même
temps donc on voit bien la séparation
que font ces grands groupes entre le
siège et les filiales et que leur
affichage dans le développement durable
et la responsabilité est souvent freinée
freiner ou par la diffusion dans des
filiales qui sont relativement autonomes
et dont ils ne revendiquent pas trop la
responsabilité et je pense que c'est un
élément important sur lequel les
consommateurs ici doivent poser qui peut
expliquer les blocages que juni trèfle a
rencontré lors de son enquête qui à la
base était une enquête marketing en fait
oui tout à fait vera j'ai écouté je
titube est un film très intéressant il
très intéressant parce qu'ils révèlent
il est révélateur à mon avis des normes
de très nombreuses questions qui sont
évidents présentes en afrique donc on
peut lire du point de vue africable et
on peut lire aussi du point de vue de la
concurrence entre les grands groupes
agroalimentaires par rapport à la
stratégie d'une multinationale qui est
localisé en suisse par rapport à son
implantation internationale donc à plein
de niveaux d'échelle de lecture moi si
je prends la lecture africaine je crois
qu'ils renvoient à des questions
on est essentielle c'est la question de
la corruption qui est un problème d'état
de droit et ça concerne un pays qui est
particulièrement concerné par cette
question
ça renvoie à la question évidemment de
la possibilité d'avoir un processus
d'industrialisation par rapport à des
groupes multinationaux en sachant qu' à
des handicaps qui peuvent tenir à la
concurrence déloyale parce que non et de
concurrence déloyale mais aussi qui
tiennent un déblocage interne il se
trouve que faire du lait ça se fait à
douala et par eux en fête du lait en
poudre transformé on ne peut pas vers
l'association qu'il faudrait faire entre
l'industrie l élevage de toute façon
l'élevage se trouve au nord dans une non
plus un secure aujourd'hui l'adamaoua et
en même temps à des coûts de transport
avec 30 chaque pas une impossibilité
d'aller jusqu'à douala donc en réalité
la firme camonin est elle-même
importatrice de lait en poudre pour le
transformer ça renvoie aux questions de
l'insertion d'un groupe dans un tissu
économique et d'accès d'être accepté par
les populations et donc de
responsabilité qui dans le cas présent
et sociales et environnementales on le
voit aussi ça envoie au fait que des
personnes licenciées non aucune
aucun système de protection sociale qui
a pas de système évidemment de chômage
ou de systèmes de prestations sociales
ça renvoie en partie au rôle du taux de
change qui dans le cas présent a été un
facteur de perte de compétitivité
donc je dirais que c'est un révélateur
de des normes de très nombreux problèmes
la seule question que je me pose c'est
pas une réserve par rapport au film
c'est évidemment la question de la
représentativité de ce cas le cas d'une
multinationale qui pratiquent alors que
son image est en cause et que
il y a un problème de responsabilité
sociale etc c'est quand même un cas
assez particulier à mon avis pour une
firme agroalimentaire qui en plus a
connu les concernent 70 et qui est en
concurrence avec des groupes qui eux
veulent se positionner évidemment par
rapport à une concurrence loyale
la prise en compte de l'environnement
c'est ça le confronte à oreille va y
revenir
jean marie bockel oui dès que un travail
destiné au public le plus large est fait
sur l'afrique comme c'est le cas avec ce
documentaire
moi je suis content parce que le
principal ennemi de l'afrique période
récente enfin des quelques décennies que
nous avons vécu de prix depuis le cri de
dumont l'afrique noire est mal partie
d'une quarantaine d'années c'est un peu
l'idée d'une espèce de terra in cognita
c'est à dire un endroit qui disparaît
des écrans radars ou en dehors de guerre
d'épidémie de révolution de misère il ne
se passe rien
or il se passe des choses en afrique
c'est le sens d'ailleurs du travail que
nous avons fait au sénat l'afrique est
notre avenir enfin l'afrique c'est
d'abord son avenir mais donc aussi le
nôtre et à partir du moment où on en
parle
et bien c'est une manière de montrer
qu'elle est douée dans l est de nouveau
dans le jeu alors il ya un autre aspect
bond par rapport à ces problèmes et dont
vous avez à l'instant très bien décrit
tous les aspects je n'y reviens pas
évidemment on peut se dire mais alors
bon bah y'a plus qu'à baisser les bras
ou enfin voilà ce une fois de plus ça y
est c'est l'afrique
on n'en sortira pas moi mon sentiment si
vous voulez entre l'afrique qui commence
vraiment à se développer vraiment aller
mieux mais vraiment aller mieux y
compris sur le terrain au niveau des
populations
lehmann la démocratie la baisse de la
corruption certains endroits mais est
une afrique qui continue à l'être images
le lie au fier le fil conducteur enfin
un des fils conducteurs
excusez moi cette expression un peu
triviale
c'est au fond l'instauration d'un
rapport de force parce qu'une société
elle progresse aussi à à partir d'un
moment où les sociétés civiles ou un
certain nombre d'intervenants de gens
qui ont des choses à dire
créé par rapport à des dés à des
pesanteurs et contre-pouvoirs le
sentiment que au fond face à ce
mastodonte ya rien à faire il ya je vais
au-delà du mou de contre-pouvoir le mot
de contre-pouvoir il est réducteur et
beaucoup dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
s'arroge un rôle de contre-pouvoir plus
ou moins réels rapport de force parce
que rapport de force s'est pas aussi
contre ce n'est pas seulement contre
pouvoir c'est aussi au sein des pouvoirs
économiques que veut faire évoluer les
mentalités de se donner des leviers des
moyens de faire changer les choses et on
est au coeur de sa au fond et ça et ça
on va en parler dans quelques instants
à travers ce cas particulier en vous
parler et vous venez d'évoquer à
philippe hugon de la concurrence
déloyale a subis par les entreprises le
cas j'aimerais qu'on réécoute jean
ziegler qui s'occupe qui s'expriment
droite documentaire pour qu'un pays
puisse se développer
qu'est-ce qu'il faut bien il faut des
murs douaniers je pars ou discutant à
genève ici et bien la suisse ne serait
jamais devenu une puissance industrielle
mondiale qu'elle est devenue sans la
protection douanière sans pouvoir ériger
une protection douanière terrienne
laquelle l'industrie nationale peu
lentement se développer à cumuler et
devenir mondialement concurrentiel ce
type de stratégie déloyal c'est monnaie
courante on africain arrive là bas je
crois que effectivement les grandes
entreprises peuvent être destructrices
d'une certaine manière
destructrice de l'environnement
prédatrice et qu' il est important comme
les 10 de leur faire peur et je crois
que la société civile a un rôle pour
faire en sorte que le citoyen se
rappelle qu'il est consommateur je crois
que cette vigilance
elle est à jouer là elle est aussi à
jouer dans le rapport syndicats aussi
houssin du cfai si les organisations
syndicales dans cette plateforme cgt et
par exemple il ya des relations d'appui
à d'autres dans d'autres pays au congo
en algérie ou ailleurs en tunisie ou
ailleurs
et donc s'il n'y a pas ce que 7,8 ce
rapport de force g mais cette tension
les entreprises peuvent écraser et être
prédatrice et empêcher de ce fait
l'émergence de d'entreprise voyait ce
rire qui sont et qui peuvent aussi être
prédatrice 1 c'est pas forcément mais
dans la mesure où elles sont liés à un
territoire
elles peuvent à ce moment là être et
vers le cadre du lait on a d'excellents
exemples justement d'entreprise qui
réussissent à être associés à leur
territoire et qui de ce fait peuvent
tenir à condition de pas être écrasé par
le bulldozer des grandes entreprises qui
vont vous lire eh bien oui enfin je
soutiens tout à fait à la fois le mot
apport de force parce que c'est un
combat c'est des rapports effectivement
tracteurs et le fait qu' il faut
évidemment avoir des contreparties pour
exprimer les lorsqu'une firme
multinationale vient dans beaucoup de
pays
évidemment la chine n'est pas comparable
elle demande de transfert de technologie
elle demande que des cadres nationaux
soient utilisés elle demande qui
évidemment des travailleurs locaux
qu'ils soient utilisés et elle demande
lot un ancrage dans le paysage bon donc
la question de multinationales des
paquets les multinationales parce que la
technologie le savoir le pouvoir
elle a beaucoup de compétences la
question est de savoir comment elle
s'insère dans le paysage en tissu
économique
comment l aile
prend en compte évidemment les dégâts
environnementaux également
éventuellement qu'elle fait et ça c'est
un rapport de force qui peut être
négociée soit par le pouvoir politique
mais on voit bien qu au cameroun c'est
pas ça qui ont des faits soit elle peut
l'être au niveau que des collectivités
territoriales il ya des négociations et
donc on peut très bien demander à nestlé
d'intervenir mais par exemple en faisant
de la sous traitance par rapport à des
pme camerounaises en laissant un espace
de liberté par rapport à des acteurs
dans des domaines où ils sont compétents
et il crée de l'emploi et donc ça c'est
de la négociation politique
or dans le cas présent ça ne s'est pas
fait alors j'ai dit rêve en fait pour
revenir sur le rapport de force il est
doublement en faveur de l'esl et parce
que l'économie endogène locale est
encore l'industrie est peu développée
donc ils se retrouvent dans une énorme
position de favorables en termes de
concurrence économique et l'état est
fragile et on le voit tous ses preuves
de corruption
bon d'abord 50 sur ckac en hauteur quand
même pas l'oublier et le la structure
étatique parce que voilà ce ne sont pas
c'est pas seulement le tissu économique
industriel qui est encore peu développé
et extravertie c'est quand même tout
près de cette afrique dont toute
l'économie est basée sur une rente de
matières premières et pas sur des
industries et et voilà cet état qui est
trop faible en fait pour imposer à une
multinationale des règles et quand il ya
des règles elles elles sont détournés je
vais je vais vous revenir vers vous tout
de suite jean marie bockel parce que si
dans votre documentaire jeudi de vous
montrer à combien l'afrique est
vulnérable c'est important de dire
qu'aujourd'hui le continent africain
c'est ce que l'on appelle un relais de
croissance autrement dit que l'afrique
possède un très fort potentiel
économique et c'est bien pour ça que les
multinationales s'y précipitent avec
plus d'un milliard d'habitants une
croissance moyenne de 5%
comment définir l'économie africaine
d'avoir est ce qu'on parle d'une ou de
plusieurs économies jean marie bockel
évidemment elle et elle est très belle
et très diverses et on peut avoir une
vision macro qui est en contradiction
avec la réalité du terrain mais elle
existe quand même et par rapport à ça je
vais dire deux choses contradictoires
la première c'est que au fond sur la
problématique de l'afrique aujourd'hui
il ya deux approches possibles
il ya ceux qui disent de toute façon
l'économie africaine ne se développera y
compris de manière endogène au service
des populations et d'un vrai
développement que le jour où un certain
nombre de préalables auront été réglées
la corruption la bonne gouvernance qui
ne sont pas à confondre ce sont deux
choses ils sont liés mais qui sont à
certains égards distinctes et d'autres
aspects les droits de l'homme la
démocratie et c'est bon il y en a
d'autres qui disent j'avais encore pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière
cette conversation à bâtons rompus avec
jean louis borloo qui est en train de
donner toute son énergie à travers sa
fondation développe en afrique et qui
disent comme lui me le disait alors que
je parlais un peu comme nous faisons oui
tu sais jean marie tu as raison mais au
fond si ce développement se poursuit à
tous les sens du terme
et bien à un moment donné ça forcément
un effet d'entraînement ça a forcément
une capacité de favoriser également des
forces qui veulent faire bouger sur les
choses à mon avis aucune des deux
théories et puis ce qui est
contradictoire par rapport à ce que je
viens de dire
enfin pas contradictoire mais au fond je
je je change de pied et en vous écoutant
maintenant je me dis et je suis ok je
suis c'est à dire je suis total l'âme
sus nous offrir le tube bolloré je suis
nestlé tout toute belle entreprise beaux
fleurons français dont pareil je suis
très fier un mea à partir de la personne
n'est parfait
je suis nestlé que ce que je fais face à
ce documentaire je m'en fiche c'est une
petite piqûre
peu de gens le verront même si vous avez
une grande diffusion de plus en plus
importante et au fond les sont passés
les chiens aboient la caravane passe
ou alors je suis un peu intelligent je
pense que les gens intelligents en arme
utile et cela et j'ai une vision un peu
géopolitique de l'avenir du groupe et je
me dis au fond moi là ok c'était un
petit truc mais ça va être vu ça va être
vu par des relais d'opinion c'est pas si
petit que ça ça va se
surtout aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux etc ça va inspirer d'autres
journalistes ou d'autres ce truc est ce
qu'on le prend tout de suite parce que
c'est simple une autre chose plus le
passé vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
on prend cette affaire au sérieux et on
se transforme vraiment dans notre
intérêt et quitte à redescendre à la
base dans les finales dans les endroits
qui on est et comme vous l'avez très
bien vie ont changé dit que vous l'avez
compris je fais un scénario là à mon
avis oui dans l'intelligent oui alors
oui exactement
on va revenir sur ces points-là moi moi
ce que je voudrais qu'on comprenne et
que les téléspectateurs comprennent
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'afrique est porteuse d'espoir
économiquement quand il le bar quand on
voit une croissance de 5% aujourd'hui
cette croissance elle est jugée solide
parce que en fait sa structure s'est
modifié plutôt si ça casse
oui mais avec des prévisions liées à la
conjoncture mondiale
mais ce qui fait l'atout de l'afrique
qu'est ce qui a changé sur ce qui fait
l'atout de l'afrique c'est sa jeunesse
d'abord et ses espaces aussi où on voit
bien que il y a des capacités et d une
jeunesse qui est davantage formés avec
des gens dans beaucoup de pays de très
très grande qualité et en plus engagée
par rapport à leur territoire et à leur
pays
ce qu'on a un peu mon peut probablement
par les gagnerait les hits de la
jeunesse oui c'est ça mais on est sa
fragilité c'est aussi eux alors sans
même en même temps en même temps
justement je voulais venir c'est clair
dans les 15 ans qui viennent on note
qu'en afrique subsaharienne il ya 330
millions de jeunes qui arrivent sur
machine emplois dont 200 millions en
milieu rural je précise dont 200
millions en milieu rural
c'est à dire que si une grande
entreprise à douala a dit moi c'est
formidable je transforme du lait du lait
en poudre et je créer 200 emplois
mais peut-être qu'il en fût 2000
ailleurs et donc je crois que le
développement de l'afrique
il doit être dans les villes c'est sûr
mais la grüne grande vigilance doit être
apportée à est injustement dans le
domaine de l'agroalimentaire c'est tout
à fait pertinent à une transformation au
plus près de la production qui
permettent un usage urbain le transport
etc et donc je pense que par rapport aux
grandes entreprises qu'on s'est
concentré il est important donc comme on
le disait d'avoir un rapport de force
par rapport aux concitoyens
consommateurs mais aussi de développer
des alternatives qui permettent de poser
et on les ong en particulier le comité
français pour les sociétés
internationales avec la fondation de
france pousse justement à la
construction de dispositifs laitiers
avec des commandes est relative et il
n'aurait une entreprise de taille
moyenne est allé dans un dans un une
ville moyenne
et c'est ancré dans le série pas gardé
avec les villes françaises souvent sur
des poseurs cités unies france est aussi
membre de mer pendant vingt ans nous
notre ville qui ce qui sonnerait de vie
avoue fruit d'une rural mais avec une
ville près de nos petits sur des
problèmes de casiers rizicoles de ces
trois là
oui excusez moi ce que j'aimerais
content parce que le développement ne
faut pas nous entraîner de vous partez
un peu ça je dois dire dans le dans le
dans la structure et de la croissance et
l'économie africaine
aujourd'hui 200 millions de foyers
africains ont des revenus supérieurs à
10 mille dollars par an ils seront a
priori 300 millions en 2020 c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'émergence de cette
émergence de la classe moyenne avait
l'émergence de la classe moyenne est
normalement pas ça si que aussi un
niveau un peu inférieur quand même pour
une partie c'est entre deux dollars par
jour pour 300 millions mais ceci étant
ça c'est un phénomène tout à fait
nouveau c'est lié aussi un phénomène
d'urbanisation qui est important ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'il ya une des
populations rurales choix que sa ferrari
fondamentale la migration est un élément
de la croissance des villes mais ça ne
l'est pas le dépeuplement des campagnes
qu'on observe vous avez aussi d'autres
éléments qui ont joué bon qui sont quand
même le niveau de formation quand même
le niveau santé globalement ses parents
y aurez vous avez plein de facteurs de
transformation
moi je pense que si on voit les défis et
je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit bhl
bars la priorité je dirais des priorités
s'il faisait said they are chizé sait
comment les jeunes qui arrivent sur un
marché du travail ou qui ont besoin
d'être insérés dans le tissu social
économique et qui ont besoin d'activités
licite rémunérés sinon c'est des
activités illicites en zone rurale et en
zone urbaine doivent on doit trouver une
réponse à ça ça c'est la priorité des
priorités donc quand on pose la question
comment ce qu'effectivement il ya une
industrie extérieur multinationales il
n'y a pas de tissu économique selon vous
ainsi le tissu économique de l'économie
informelle où il existe à 80% c'est
quand même ce qui permet à des jeunes
accords et la question est comment par
rapport aux nouveaux arrivants on
trouvera une réponse à la question en
milieu rural du droit foncier c'est la
question en zone urbaine de savoir quels
sont des activités qu'on peut trouver
donc je pense que par rapport à ça quel
que soit le secteur dans lequel vous
travaillez dans le cas présent c'est
l'agroalimentaire mais ça peut être dans
d'autres activités
comment secret des relations qui peuvent
être des relations contractuelles qui
m'avait des relations de sous traitance
qui peuvent être des relations de
complémentarité il ya la concurrence
mais aussi à la complémentarité en zone
rurale et aux zones urbaines et en zone
rurale c'est quoi c'est que
l'agriculture essentiellement familial
soit modernisée mais qu'elle continue
d'exister même si l agrobusiness vous
êtes en train de dire qu'il y aura un
décrochage entre le rural et l'urbain
non non non non on compte c'est la même
question en zone rurale et aux zones
urbaines oui sauf que évidemment c'est
pas polémiquer vite et sait comment
est-ce qu'on associe l'agriculture et
l'élevage comme on associe agriculture l
industrie et l élevage et l'industrie
dans le cas présent le projet industrie
quels sont les pays à plus fort
potentiel parce que il ya de grandes
disparités en appelait alors ça n'est
pas en quoi et ensuite mais les
multinationales est longue et non mes
choix des musiques oui mais il ya enfin
il ya des sociétés comment dirais-je les
choses évoluent les choses ne sont pas
figées
il ya des pays ou des régions qui à un
moment donné ne vont pas bien n'ont pas
la chance d'avoir un certain nombre
d'investissements notamment de
multinationales et prennent le taureau
par les cornes si je puis dire et
s'inventent des modèles de développement
qui ensuite deviennent des
success-stories qui peuvent d'ailleurs
parfois assez vite d'être détruite si on
n'y prend garde moi parce que je vous
donne un exemple et je n'ai pas encore
la réponse à ma question devient
peut-être vous avez mis à d tout au long
de notre rapport sur l'avenir de
l'afrique
on s'est à plusieurs reprises poser la
question de savoir s'il y avait comment
dirais-je à 1
une malédiction de l'afrique francophone
par rapport aux différents facteurs d'un
bon développement etc
et franchement si on se posait la
question c'est que quelque part il nous
arrivait de le penser
agacé que nous étions inquiets que nous
étions par rapport à un certain nombre
de situations dramatiques que l'on
connaît dans cette partie de l'afrique
et eux et en fait on n'a pas trouvé la
réponse parce que si on regarde sur un
temps un peu plus long que la
photographie d'aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
dans l'afrique ex francophone je parle
de la lande mais c'est lié aux ex
colonies naturellement anglophones
allophones cnra il ya eu des hauts et
des bas bon le mozambique est
aujourd'hui une success story avec des
points de fragilité j'ai connu comme
jeune députée présidente france
mozambique la guerre civile les années
80 c'était l'horreur absolue
et on pourrait parler de l'angola où il
y aurait encore beaucoup à dire
d'ailleurs
et on pourrait parler bon donc j'ai
toujours pas la réponse à cette question
mais si je vous raconte cette anecdote à
cette anecdote 7
ce questionnement c'est parce que il y a
quand même une grande diversité et c'est
pas statique on parlait tout à l'heure
en attendant l'émission par rapport à
une phrase prononcée par un homme
politique français l'importance de la
notion d' apartheid
ah oui je vous entendez je connais aussi
un petit peu cette présence avait
présidé le groupe d'étude sur
l'apartheid avant que que mandela ne
soient libérés tous a beaucoup intéressé
à ces questions bon là aussi c'est une
société quand même qui a énormément
bougé nommé lire l'histoire même si
l'argent est justement de l'histoire
l'afrique c'est pas une photographe
qu'est ce qu'on trouve comme cas de
figure parmi les entreprises qui sont
présentes en afrique
est-ce qu'elle fonctionne
essentiellement tout comme nestlé comme
ce qu'on vient de voir au risque que
justement il ya des différences d'un
confrère je pense par exemple je sais
que
la société c'est moi le premier
fabricant de chocolat français qui
achètent 3% de la population mondiale va
produire fabriqués sur place son cacao
en côte d'ivoire qu'est ce que oui mais
vous allez me dire qu'il ya d'autres ça
c'est un exemple que j'ai lu il y en a
certainement d'auteur qui rit alors
j'évite comme vous avez travaillé sur ce
dossier là oui bah il ya des pme en
afrique de taille importante qui en a
bien sûr il ya des il ya des sociétés en
côte d'ivoire dans tous les pays de la
danse chaque région on va dire y'a un
pays phare avec une industrie c'est pas
du tout une existence c'est encore pas
assez développée mais les bienfaits plus
difficile pour une pme que pour une
utilisation
c'est pas forcément difficile
il ya dans le cas de codilait évidemment
on est arrivé il faut sauver juste
rappeler c'est que déceler le propos
c'est que monsieur bicec a fait donc à
nestlé s'étend à d'autres entreprises
donc s'est trouvé seul en fait face à
d'autres entreprises qui ont pratiqué
les mêmes le même type de pratique on
voit là de falsification on va dire du
lait donc c'est pas c'est pas un cas
isolé un cas isolé à la question est de
savoir si les procédés d'implantation
sont relativement les mêmes sons je vous
en prie avant moi qu'il ya deux choses
la première chose c'est que j'aimerais
effectivement qu'il y ait en afrique des
services commerciaux et des
représentants des grandes régions
françaises
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils font ce que
j'ai vu fer en chine ou même au vietnam
où il ya eu un effort public important
pour sur place pour aider les
entreprises françaises à réaliser dans
une bonne compréhension des tissus donc
se faire dans des gros pays prenait
d'ethiopie poil alors oui c'est l'argent
c'est en train de changer
la deuxième l'a dit oui alors c'est vrai
que là dessus la france est un petit peu
en refaire parmi d'autres en allemand
vous vient l'envié ma vallée le fait
colonial et le problème de la france et
le
fantômes du passé colonial et puis je
pense qu'on n'a pas forcément une image
je vais prendre parallèle non pas avec
les entreprises je vais faire en
parallèle en sortant des entreprises
pour voir les universités je t'arrête
pas mal sur les relations sur moi j'y
étais quels sont les universités
françaises qui ont une coopération
équilibrée avec les universités
africaines et ben c'est plutôt le droid
davantage au groenland
mais bon on pourrait dire un truc un peu
provocateur par rapport à ça si vous
permettez
bon moi je suis premier à être très
autocritique sur toutes les erreurs
qu'on a pu commettre depuis l'époque de
la décolonisation et qui d'ailleurs sont
allés contre d'autres intérêts mais je
pense que là on a une bonne fenêtre pas
uniquement sur le raisons géopolitiques
en fin tragique en fin tragique qui sont
d'actualité mais aussi parce que on en
sort on sort pas de la période chinoise
elle continue mais au sort de la période
de fascination total par rapport à
l'arrivée de la chine
ces investissements non conditionnels
l'argent qui se déverse et les africains
qui sont aussi intelligents que nous et
une came prix les effets pervers 1 2
alors encore une fois c'est bien que la
chine soit là c'est bien que le brésil
le mexique l'un d'eux enfin tous ces
pays ces grands pays émergents riches
soient là ça crée une diversité ça crée
une compétition ça montre que l'afrique
est devenue une terre maintenant
investissement attractif même parfois
mais il ya aujourd'hui par rapport
notamment en afrique francophone mais
aussi dans des pays d'afrique anglophone
où il ya une sorte d'attentes de
francophonie pas forcément la langue 1
mais une certaine relation ils se disent
bon vous avez beaucoup de défauts vous
avez fait des erreurs mais on vous
connaît bien voilà assez on a aussi ses
deux enfants
et on a vu quand même que on pouvait
bâtir avec vous renverrai on ne veut pas
la seule chine
on ne veut pas le seul et n'a dû son sol
il ya une fenêtre il ya une attente à
nous de savoir si les parlements moi je
pense que les conditions ont fortement
changé depuis le début en gros 2 du 20e
siècle
l'africa diversité diversifier ses
partenaires et il se trouve que les
français étaient présents
essentiellement par des grands groupes
qu'on connaît bien c'est bolloré
bouygues total c'est bien si c'est
orange etc
par contre on avait très peu de pme
français qui prenaient le risque
d'investissement alors que aujourd'hui
il est extrêmement important par rapport
à des opportunités de marché
d'arriver à des formes de jive un tueur
seul de faire en mobilisant d'ailleurs
la diaspora africaine qui est en france
qui est un élément aussi moteur pour
l'investissement d'arriver à retrouver
des dépositions
donc je pense que la france en gros a
maintenus globalement ses parts de
marché à l'afrique
globalement mais c'est à dire qu'elle en
a perdu considérablement valeur relative
parce qu'entre temps le commerce
extérieur a augmenté très fortement
alors alors alors justement avançons
comment la consommation africaine
peut-elle aboutir à une
industrialisation positive et quels sont
les obstacles
je vous propose qu'on réécoute un
extrait du documentaire nous voulons
nous battre pour que la croissance et le
développement de notre pays soit une
réalité pour que nos enfants aient des
emplois au cameroun vous trouvez normal
qu on les enfants aillent mourir à
lampedusa que le parent se déplacent
qu'il pleure moi je dit que vraiment
arrêtons de gérer les jérémiades
qu'on ne vienne pas démolir nos usines
que nous mouvements de menton les
investissements cette usine là elle
emploie 200 personnes
un vitesse de pointe 200 emplois
bon alors si on résume un peu les
ressources en afrique sont considérables
on l'a dit mais leur exploitation ne
crée pas d'emplois massivement
l'agriculture et très peu modernisé en
2040 l'afrique aura la population en âge
de travailler la plus importante au
monde
donc l'emploi par voie de conséquence va
devenir une priorité des gouvernements
donc question est ce que aujourd'hui les
entreprises ne doivent pas changer
d'état d'esprit dès maintenant est
comment le b à ba c'est les afriques
c'est à dire qu'il ya de plus en plus de
chefs d'entreprises africains sous
différentes formes
un capitalistique coopérative et cetera
ça s'est beaucoup développée donc
derrière il ya des enjeux de formation
et là on peut être des partenaires et
des enjeux d' expertise et là on peut
être des partenaires
c'est au moins aussi important que ce
que feront nos propres pme dans notre
intérêt et sait très bien qu'on
travaille dans l'intérêt c'est un bon
moteur mais je pense enfin pour moi
l'avenir c'est quand même ça vous savez
quelle est la principale immigration en
afrique aujourd'hui puisqu'on parle de
lampedusa ça c'est l'immigration de
l'afrique à l'afrique
donc je vire ont des plans comme dixième
de la mélasse voilà donc on est encore
dans des situations souvent fin
complètement imprévisible dramatique
facteurs aussi de tensions de 2,0 phobie
interne etc
la réponse elle est d'abord africaine 1
et n'ayant pas l'air d'avoir une fois de
plus le regard ce qu'elles ont dit aux
africains
voilà ce qu'il faut faire après on a
aussi un rôle à jouer bien sûr mais est
ce que la clé c'est pas créer un
écosystème local ce qui en tout cas là
qu'il dit beaucoup de choses
oui entre dans la classe effectivement
s'attaquer aux prunes de structure c'est
vraiment ça que le film essaye de
montrer parce que ça commence en 94 avec
la dévaluation du franc cfa et ça dure
sur 20 ans et ses 20 ans où tout tout
est venu de l'extérieur et les conseils
du fmi et rémy ajustements structurels
vous devez faire si vous devez faire ça
et l'investissement extérieur et voilà
extérieur toujours et même l'aide au
développement quelque part oui avec des
bonnes intentions mais seulement par
intérêt mais aussi avec des bonnes
intentions mais tout est et la voilà il
faut renverser ça et c'est vraiment des
problèmes structurels alors par exemple
un petit exemple pour illustrer
l'importance de la recherche
développement
c'est crucial pour une économie il y
avait en côte d'ivoire un institut
d'agronomie qui a développé un riz
africain unique qui
en croisant des espèces qui a été à la
fois robuste par rapport au climat et
qui donne les rendements élevés et ben
serait africain qui est donc été mis au
point par des agronomes africains à
bouaké en côte d'ivoire il pouvait pas
arriver jusqu'aux consommateurs parce
qu'il était concurrencé par déry venus
d'asie beaucoup moins cher qui arrivés
par bateau et qui était va donc cesser
ces cinq ans je parle plus sur elle
c'est de ça dont il s'agit
si on veut il faut donner assez payé à
ce continent en fait le cadre en fait
les réglementations la réglementation le
cadre qui permette à l'équipe
il a d'abord produit vous avez parlé
effectivement je crois que c'est ça le
bon terme c'est comme on crée des
écosystèmes pas nécessairement
d'ailleurs uniquement localisée parce
qu'ils peuvent être interconnectés
aujourd'hui évidemment par rapport à
l'économie mondiale qu'est-ce qu'on va
comme élément très positif vis-à-vis de
l'afrique
d'abord vous avez des ressources a été
rappelé vous avez des ressources
humaines vous avez des ressources en
matières premières considérable europe
des ressorts son énergie considérable
vous avez énormément de jeunes qui ont
des capacités d'innover qui ont des
niveaux de formation et qui sont prêts à
modifier les structures et à agir alors
la question c'est évidemment comment
est-ce qu'on laisse s'épanouir ces
différentes initiatives
c'est des questions de prise de risque
il faut savoir que la prise de risque
d'un investisseur dans le domaine
industriel par exemple comme l
entreprise et hier c'était lent parce
que vous dépendez de tellement de
facteurs ce que vous allez pas investir
facilement par rapport à un horizon de
long terme donc vous faites du court
terme vous acheter du riz plutôt que
vous le planter pour simplifier donc
comment est ce que on crée un
environnement qui permettent la prise de
risques comme manquerait également des
législations mais qui permettent des
panouilles
les potentialités et je crois que le
tout se fait quand même dans une
ouverture extérieure parce que j'ai
entendu ziegler qui dit faut protéger
morts ça veut dire quoi protéger
aujourd'hui dans le monde
mais aujourd'hui les bancaires sont
complètement poreuse n'allait pas créer
une industrie laitière protégé au
cameroun alors puisque par exemple et
vous avez cité rien est-ce que
l'instabilité politique
nancy est est ce que est est ce que
justement le problème de l'insécurité
obligé politique aussi est un problème
oui oui mais président n'est pas
indirectement ce qui ce qui fait que
l'afrique aujourd'hui un taux de
rentabilité très élevée mais parce que
vous avez aussi d'investissements à
court terme c'est que vous avez un taux
de retour à regarder la téléphonie
mobile
oui l'afrique est passée de l'acte label
sony mobile
il ya deux choses quand même qu'ils sont
avérées effectivement il ya une ong qui
croient s'appelle douaniers sans
frontières qui est un paradoxe comment
exploiter des douaniers pour que
effectivement le système africain qui
est le plus ouvert au monde
les agriculteurs africains le disent
nous on n'a pas de système de protection
donc on est défendue contre rien et je
pense que c'est une faiblesse donc là je
roulais à l'échelle à les régionales à
l'échelle régionale
ce n'est pas le libéralisme forêt les
paladins chose il ya une deuxième suite
par rapport aux enjeux de capacité
politique c'est que je constate que
depuis une dizaine d'années la
décentralisation en afrique a fait des
progrès considérables en afrique et dans
d'autres pays la jante d'haïti où ça
aussi en train de faire bouger les
choses et qui donc il ya des espaces
bien de cohérence politique qui sont
favorables à l'émergence d'acteurs
économiques à condition qu'un certain
nombre de conditions
c'est qu'ils aient un accès au crédit et
qu'ils ne soient pas et qu'il soit d'une
certaine manière pas écrasés par le
bulldozer de d'une intervention
extérieure qui viendrait
mais même dans des pays dont on peut
considérer vu d'ici qui vont mal il y à
des initiatives formidables et où
justement un certain nombre de deux
territoires d'acteurs de groupes de
coopérateurs de deux groupes de femmes
femmes ont un rôle considérable dans
tous ces mouvements là et qu'ils
profitent de la de l'urbanisation et de
l'augmentation même faible du niveau de
vie qui à mon avis n'est avec je suis ok
avec l' agence avec la fondation de
france le comité français pour la
solidarité internationale et avec les
donateurs de ces deux groupes
on a fait nourrir la ville avec
l'agriculture familiale un ensemble de
situations positives où on voit bien
effectivement que progressivement il y à
des modèles qui se développe et qui
peuvent se multiplier en relation entre
des acteurs de terrain des universités
effectivement l'université jobs
alors eh bien les premières qui ont trop
surpris oui est ce qu'il vous faut pour
louis bal et souley comment dirais-je ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur la montée
en puissance de la jeunesse africaine
les chiffres les prospectives même si
elles sont toujours un peu fausse mais
les ordres de grandeur on le connait
c'est vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
c'est impressionnant donc forcément ça
ne sera pas solutionné par la seule
immigration qu'elles soient internes ou
externes
ça ne sera pas solutionné par les seules
réponses formidable qu'on apporte déjà
sur le terrain donc mais qui ont ça va
donc forcément nous ramener aux rapports
de force c'est à dire que les classes
politiques les responsables politiques
où ils vont voler en éclats de manière
accélérée avec tous les dangers qui
pourraient y avait derrière on voit ce
qui se passe dans des pays comme le
niger aujourd'hui en fin de
l'obstruction
une présence française ça n'a pas
empêché bon mais c'est un exemple parce
qu'il est récent donc où on va vers une
sorte de chaos pendant un certain nombre
d'années
moi je suis plutôt optimiste où ça va
être un puissant moteur à ce qu'émerge
bien sûr sur le plan économique de la
société civile mais aussi au niveau des
responsables politiques des générations
de gens qu'ils abandonnaient devant la
nécessité agissent vraiment et là il
peut se passer des trucs plus vite qu'on
ne le pense
vous êtes d'accélération au pouvoir au
contraire on arrive au terme du débat
via le personnel politique en afrique il
ya énormément de compétences et je pense
qu'il ya peut-être aussi un élément
intéressant de retour d'une élite formée
à l'étranger et qui a tendance à revenir
vers eux c'est très bon signe et c'est
certainement porter deux pour la finale
dès ce mois alors gardons espoir pour
l'afrique merci à tous d'être venus sur
ce plateau
la semaine prochaine vous retrouverez
bien sûr laurent bazin pour un
documentaire sur la crise des missiles
de cuba et puis moi je vous retrouve
dans 15 jours pour un débat sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens a très vite
et sur public sénat
fou